[Applaudissements]
prier rêver se former se transformer
créer sa propre révolution
c'est de notre responsabilité
bonsoir
je vais vous embarquer
dans l'aventure
la vie de ses mails
nous sommes dans les années 70 je dirais
enfin des années 70
à Bouaké
c'est Maé est une jeune fille une petite
fille insouciante heureuse avec ses
parents
c'est Maé va à l'école dans une école
commence l'école
dans une école française
prends de bonnes habitudes
commencez à apprécier les bibliothèques
apprend à nager
Bella petite vie de princesse de son
père la petite choco comme on dirait en
Côte d'Ivoire
malheureusement
il y a un basculement dans sa vie le
divorce de ses parents
en chamboulement total
déménagement dans une autre ville
je vais vous faire voyager on va passer
de Bouaké à Daloa
et c'est le début de cauchemar de la
petite cima
son père se remarie
et elle apprend à vivre dans l'adversité
avec une marâtre acariâtre
une marâtre qui lui prédit
une vie de rue
une marâtre qui lui fait vivre l'enfer
c'est Maé c'est moi
j'étais une élève brillante
j'ai eu pu avoir une bourse d'étude
pour entrer en classe de 6e
mais malheureusement les conditions de
cette nouvelle vie ne m'ont pas permis
de continuer sur cette lancée
je n'avais pas le droit de me nourrir à
la maison
je marchais 8 km 4 pour me rendre à
l'école
c'était de l'eau bien du quartier loubia
au lycée en
alors j'ai appris à me débrouiller
entre 10 ans et 14 ans
vous savez sa forge déjà
un caractère
je pourrais parler déjà de prémices de
stoïcisme d'apprentissage de stoïcisme
alors je suis en échec scolaire en
classe de 5e
et cet échec fut salutaire parce que ma
mère
a dû me récupérer pour vivre avec elle
malgré elle ces conditions précaires
alors c'est une nouvelle vie qui démarre
une autre vie qui démarre avec ma mère
à Abidjan
j'apprends à vivre dans les quartiers un
salut
nous étions à te couper il n'y avait pas
d'eau
et elle a réussi à évoluer en changeant
de quartier pour passer d'un découper au
220 logements à Adjamé c'était une
grande évolution pour nous nous avions
un minimum
de l'eau et de l'électricité
un minimum de commodité
démarre pour moi une vie de nomade
scolaires
parce que ma mère
tenait compte d'opportunités qu'elle
pouvait trouver pour me scolariser ici
et là
je commence par un Beauville chez les
bonnes sœurs
pour certainement
transformer mon état d'esprit
ensuite à Yamoussoukro
chez un tuteur
et par la suite je rentre à Abidjan
où j'ai pu avoir mon bac et continuer
une partie de mes études
alors
ce moment 7
c'est construit ainsi
mon mindset s'est construit dans cette
vie de vulnérabilité mais avec une
chance il sera ordinaire c'était celle
d'avoir une mère aimante une mère qui
savait rester digne malgré ces
difficultés
je vais prendre pour exemple les
dentelles se cachait parce qu'elle
n'arrivait pas du tout à payer son loyer
de 30000 francs Cfa je parle de 45 euros
se cachait de la propriétaire parce
qu'elle n'arrivait pas à honorer ses
engagements
ou cette mère qui a du ventre quelques
bijoux quelques babioles je dirais
pour me sortir de pour sortir des frais
d'hospitalisation pour moins de 20 000
Français
c'est avec cette mère aimante que j'ai
pu traverser ces moments d'adolescence
parce que je n'ai pas eu de
pré-adolescence j'ai pas eu d'enfance
c'est avec cette mère que j'ai eu cette
grâce de pouvoir m'envoler et je suis
passé d'Adjamé
au 16e arrondissement de Paris sans
transition
sans transition
[Applaudissements]
d'Adjamé ou 220 logements
à Paris 16e arrondissement par le
mariage je me suis mariée assez tôt
et le rêve j'en avais un j'en avais
qu'un seul c'était celui de sortir ma
mère et sa famille de cette précarité
c'était celui
de devenir le pilier d'une famille ça
c'est imposé à moi de fait
avant de partir à Paris j'avais une vie
dans les livres
j'avais une superbe vie dans les livres
je savais colorer mon esprit avec les
livres c'est ce qui m'a toujours porté
c'est ce qui m'a toujours accompagnée
donc quand je dis que je suis passé
d'Adjamé au 16e c'était une transition
réelle mais qu'il était pas dans mon
esprit
parce que je savais déjà voyager dans la
tête
j'ai monté ma première entreprise
en 1998 une entreprise familiale pour
soutenir véritablement
les la famille qui était restée en Côte
d'Ivoire je commence dans l'agriculture
la vie culture et le transport
mais j'ai besoin de rentrer
pour veiller à la marche des entreprises
que j'avais montées
je rentre en Côte d'Ivoire et j'ai
l'opportunité de faire des expériences
en banque et dans le café cacao
mais le virus entrepreneurial a pris le
dessus
quand j'ai eu l'opportunité avec
les éléphants de Côte d'Ivoire qui
allaient pour la première fois
participer à la Coupe du monde
à ce moment-là j'ai franchi le pas pour
m'impliquer davantage dans mes affaires
et j'ai dû monter une autre entreprise
parler de rêve
on peut parler de rêve mais comment
parler de rêve sans action
je vais vous parler de 2014 qui pour moi
est une année de sérendipité vous savez
la sérendipité c'est de trouver ce qu'on
ne cherche pas
et pour l'illustrer en 2014 je rentre au
Conseil économique social
environnemental et culturel et je suis
la première surprise parce que je la
prends par voix de presse
je suis la première surprise
et sur cette image
j'ai l'opportunité
et l'audace je dirais de traverser le
protocole pour rencontrer pour la
première fois le président de la
République de Côte d'Ivoire et le
remercier
de m'avoir nommé dans cette institution
je le rencontrais pour la première fois
j'ai fini par savoir
qui était cet ange qui m'avait proposé
au cézette le président Marcel zadies
ici mais cette sérendipité qu'on peut
appeler la grâce qu'on peut appeler du
hasard
c'est inscrit tout le long de mon
parcours
trouver ce que je ne cherche pas
et quand on trouve on se rend compte que
dans l'action on arrive à aller plus
loin
retenez la notion de sérendipité parce
que tout le long de mon ici c'est
quelque chose qui va revenir
alors mon activité première
qui s'est inscrit dans le monde dans le
monde du sport et qui continue
d'ailleurs 17 ans après
au fil du temps nous sommes passés
d'activités sportives aux activités
économiques on a dû s'intéresser pour
développer nos notre entreprise la
palette on a dû s'intéresser aux
activités économiques
alors il nous vient l'idée
qu'on apprend encore par voie de presse
un voyage d'État du président de la
République
à Marrakech
je ne sais pas s'il est dans la salle
Stéphanie Ollier mais avec avec cet ami
là on décide
de s'inviter à cette visite des temps
au secteur privé j'entends
ce secteur privé souhaite fait partie
des voyages des missions d'État du
président de la République mais comment
faire on n'est pas invité
à 48 heures du voyage du président
je décide à fêter un avion sans avoir de
moyens
alors j'aimerais je remets un chèque à
la vie au nord 48 heures avant le départ
du chef de l'État et je me dis ça va
être très simple il me suffit de passer
quelques coups de fil et c'est dans la
boucle et ben non ça marche pas comme ça
je vais faire un chèque
et je n'ai pas de clients on a fait ton
avion il y a pas un seul client
en dehors de cet ami très enthousiaste
passionné qui m'encourageait à le faire
alors véritablement vous savez tous les
opérateurs économiques tous les chefs
d'entreprise dans cette salle
connaissent bien ces moments de solitude
où vous avez par moment des éclairs je
décide
d'écrire au secrétaire général de la
présidence de la République pour lui
dire que je lui offrais des places pour
sa délégation la délégation
présidentielle
évidemment ça fait tilt tout le monde
aime la gratuité
ils sont pressent de me répondre et le
lendemain il y a le chef de cabinet qui
m'appelle qui me dit vous offrez
vraiment une vous offrez vraiment ce
voyage à la délégation je dis mais bien
sûr que si il y a aucun problème il est
temps d'inverser la tendance que le
secteur privé accompagne le gouvernement
faut qu'on arrive à cela
donc oui
[Applaudissements]
donc oui nous avons affrêter un avion
nous sommes un certain nombre
d'opérateurs économiques on souhaite
participer au voyage et en même temps
vous accompagner parce que c'est nous
qui payons les impôts on est supposé
vous soutenir n'est-ce pas
ils sont presque de me remettre une
liste je peux vous assurer que c'est
cette liste qui m'a permis de remplir le
vol
parce que dès que je suis sortie de ce
rendez-vous j'ai lancé un message dans
tout le réseau en leur disant vous avez
toute la délégation présidentielle sur
mon vol
je puis vous assurer que j'avais plus de
place ils sont tous venus
[Applaudissements]
ils sont tous venus
nous avons réussi quelque chose
alors on va parler des quatre C en
termes d'action à mener pour parler de
révolution
les quatre C je vais avoir besoin de
vous
je vais avoir besoin de vous pour parler
des quatre C
le
C de la capacité
nous avons une capacité énorme notre
capacité de nous former notre capacité
de nous construire
vous allez répéter avec moi capacité
le deuxième C
c'est notre crédibilité
il est important d'inspirer confiance
et de faire confiance
vous allez répéter avec moi crédibilité
et le troisième c'est
c'est quoi le troisième C
oh formidable comment vous savez ça ah
oui
la connexion je suis connecté à vous ce
soir parce que la connexion se doit
d'être positive tous autant que nous
sommes dans cette salle on doit être
dans une connexion positive et
constructive dont je vous exhorte à vous
connecter et le quatrième C c'est le
capital ce capital spirituel dont on a
besoin ce capital humain qui nous permet
de nous établir des lignes et de pouvoir
avancer ce capital financier qui n'est
qu'une finalité parce qu'il nous faut
les trois premiers C pour naturellement
avoir le quatrième qui est le capital
financier
ces quatre c'est fondent véritablement
mon état d'esprit fondement
je ne puis être ce soir avec vous
c'est vrai qu'on a une minute de silence
pour le président Bédié mais c'est ton
devoir pour moi
un devoir pour moi un devoir de
gratitude un devoir de gratitude pour
des personnes qui ont traversé ma vie
et qui m'ont forgé qui ont fait de moi
ce que je suis je ne puis être là
sans rendre hommage
au président
Marcel sadicacim
Henri Konan Bédié qui est ton père
à mon père biologique qui malgré tout
malgré cette marathe acariâtre a su à
distance s'occuper de moi
et rendre hommage avoir une pensée émue
pour un ami un ami précieux le Premier
ministre Amadou Gon Coulibaly
je vais partager avec vous
ce rêve qui est généreux et qui est
gratuit
le rêve généreux le rêve est gratuit
on va simplement
demander à Dieu
qui nous offre le rêve
de nous mettre à l'idée de passer à
l'action tout se joue dans l'action tout
ce jour dans les pas que nous menons pas
à prépa tout se joue dans les marches
avec enseignement avec formation
avec un intelligence
à pouvoir saisir les opportunités et
créer notre révolution
j'avais une musique
qui devrait passer
maintenant pour la fin
[Musique]
alors chacun doit piler son foutou
passons à l'action
on rêve parce que nous en avons les
capacités on rêve parce que nous sommes
crédibles on peut rêver parce que le
capital naturellement nous accompagnera
mais le plus important véritablement ici
ce sont des connexions
je suis c'est Maé
mon rêve à moi c'est d'être la meilleure
version de moi-même je suis sémaé mon
rêve à moi c'est d'impacter
mes actions au quotidien et j'insiste
sur le mot impact
impacter ma communauté
impacter ma famille bien entendu qui
était le rêve de base
et mon secret le secret de symae
c'est la foi
la détermination et la zénitude je
[Applaudissements]